It's peak pollination season and my business is scaling fast. To keep the nectar flowing, I need a phone plan with top priority data speeds. That's why I chose Google Fi Wireless. My connections stay strong even when the hive is buzzing. Plus, unlimited plans started $35 a month. Now that's a deal that doesn't stay. Explore Google Fi Wireless plans today. Plus taxes and government fees.
现在是授粉高峰期，我的业务发展迅速。为了让花蜜源源不断，我需要一个拥有最高优先级数据速度的手机套餐。这就是我选择 Google Fi Wireless 的原因。即使蜂巢喧闹，我的连接依然强劲。此外，无限流量套餐起价为每月 35 美元。这绝对是一个不会长久的优惠。立即探索 Google Fi Wireless 套餐。需加收税费和政府规费。
Google Fi Wireless is not subject to data traffic deprioritization during times of high network usage. Speaking of Psychology is taking a winter break. So we're rerunning some of our favorite episodes from the past. Last year, I talked to researcher Vioreka Marion about why speaking multiple languages is good for the brain and about how language shapes the way we see the world. We hope you enjoy this episode from the archives. Speaking of Psychology will be back with new episodes in early January. Thank you for listening.
在网络高流量期间，Google Fi Wireless 不会受到数据流量降速的影响。《心理学话题》正在放寒冬假。因此，我们将重播过去一些我们最喜欢的节目。去年，我与研究人员维奥雷卡·马里恩探讨了为什么会说多种语言对大脑有益，以及语言如何塑造我们看世界的方式。我们希望您喜欢这期来自档案的节目。1 月初，《心理学话题》将带着新节目回归。谢谢收听。
Over the past 40 years, the number of people in the United States who speak a language other than English at home has nearly tripled to 68 million. That's about one in every five Americans. And in many other parts of the world, bilingualism and multilingualism are even more common. In fact, more than half the world's population speaks more than one language. In recent years, scientists have begun to explore what's going on in the brains of people who are bilingual or multilingual. And they found evidence that speaking multiple languages,
在过去的 40 年里，美国在家中说英语以外语言的人数几乎翻了三番，达到 6800 万。这大约占每五个美国人中的一个。在世界许多其他地方，双语和多语现象更为常见。事实上，世界上半数以上的人口说不止一种语言。近年来，科学家们开始探索双语或多语人群的大脑中究竟发生了什么。他们发现证据表明，会说多种语言，
may have cognitive benefits that include improving people's executive function abilities and slowing down the progression of age-related dementia. Researchers are also learning more about how the bilingual brain processes language and how the languages we speak shape the way we think and perceive the world. So why might speaking multiple languages have such far-reaching benefits? How does the brain process more than one language at a time? How do the languages we speak affect the way we see the world and the decisions we make? And what counts as being bilingual?
可能会带来认知益处，包括提高人们的执行功能能力以及延缓与年龄相关的痴呆症的发展。研究人员还在进一步了解双语大脑如何处理语言，以及我们所说的语言如何塑造我们的思维和对世界的感知。那么，为什么说多种语言会有如此深远的好处呢？大脑是如何同时处理一种以上语言的？我们所说的语言如何影响我们看待世界的方式和我们做出的决定？什么才算双语？
Are people who are fluent in computer code or even math or music bilingual? And finally, if you're interested in the benefits of learning a new language, is it ever too late to try? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Villarica Marion, a professor in the Department of Psychology and Communication Sciences and Disorders at Northwestern University. She's a psychologist and cognitive scientist whose research focuses on bilingualism and multilingualism. She studies the relationship between language and memory, as well as how people process spoken and written language.
精通计算机代码甚至数学或音乐的人算不算双语？最后，如果您对学习一门新语言的好处感兴趣，现在尝试是否会为时已晚？欢迎收听“心理学话题”，这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。我今天的嘉宾是西北大学心理学与沟通科学及障碍系教授维拉莉卡·马里恩博士。她是一位心理学家和认知科学家，其研究重点是双语和多语现象。她研究语言与记忆之间的关系，以及人们如何处理口头和书面语言。
Dr. Marion is the author of the recent book, The Power of Language. how the codes we used to think, speak, and live transform our minds. Dr. Marion, thank you for joining me today. Thank you for having me. It's good to be here. You open your book with an epigraph. To have another language is to possess another soul. Why did you choose that quote? What does it mean to you?
马里恩博士是近期出版的新书《语言的力量：我们用于思考、说话和生活的代码如何改变我们的思维》的作者。马里恩博士，非常感谢您今天能来做客。谢谢您的邀请。很高兴来到这里。您的书是以一句题词开头的：“掌握另一种语言，就拥有另一个灵魂。”您为什么选择这句名言？它对您意味着什么？
I chose that quote because it reflects on what people who speak to or more languages often experience, that when they use their different. languages, they become slightly different versions of themselves. With each language bringing to the forefront, different cultural experiences, different memories, different aspects of their identity, different relationships, and in a way serving as a filter through which they see the world and interact with themselves, with others, and with the world at large. Now, you speak multiple languages, including Romanian, Russian, and English. How did your own early experiences of language lead you to the work that you're doing now? Yeah, so I grew up in a family that spoke
我之所以选择这句名言，是因为它反映了会说两种或多种语言的人经常体验到的一种现象：当他们使用不同的语言时，他们会变成稍微不同的自己。每种语言都会把不同的文化体验、不同的记忆、不同的身份认同以及不同的人际关系带到前台，并在某种程度上充当一种滤镜，让他们通过它来看待世界，并与自己、他人以及整个世界进行互动。现在，您会说多种语言，包括罗马尼亚语、俄语和英语。您自己早期的语言经历是如何引导您走向现在的工作的？是的，我在一个家庭中长大，家里说的是
Romanian at home in one of the former Soviet republics where Russian was the official language outside the home. So I went to Russian child care and grew up with both Romanian and Russian in parallel. Then later in school, I started to study English, then in college, French, then I've learned some Spanish that I married into a Dutch family and ended up really being exposed to a variety of languages, which as you mentioned earlier in your introduction is very common, not only in Europe, but in many different parts of the world. In countries, pretty much every continent, people often speak two more languages from early childhood and then acquire additional languages often later in life. So it is very common for the human condition to really be a bilingual, multilingual one. When you call someone bilingual, does that mean the person grew up speaking two languages, or can you become bilingual later in life by studying another language and becoming fluent?
在罗马尼亚语中，在前苏联加盟共和国之一的家里，俄语是家门外的官方语言。所以我上了俄语托儿所，同时接触了罗马尼亚语和俄语。后来在学校里，我开始学英语，上大学时学了法语，后来又学了一些西班牙语，然后我嫁给了一个荷兰家庭，最终真正接触到了各种各样的语言，正如你在节目开头提到的那样，这不仅在欧洲非常普遍，在世界许多不同地方也是如此。在几乎各大洲的国家里，人们通常从小就说两种或多种语言，然后在生命的晚期经常习得其他语言。因此，双语和多语状态确实是人类的一种非常普遍的生存状况。当你称某人为双语者时，是指这个人从小就会说两种语言，还是可以通过以后学习另一语言并达到流利来成为双语者？
In other words, I'm looking for a definition. You can become bilingual at any age, so you don't have to grow up with two languages to be bilingual. You can learn a second language in childhood, in adolescence, in adulthood, and even in your older age. A bilingual is a person who can use two languages. A multilingual is a person who knows and can use more than two languages. So the definition of bilingualism is broad, and it depends, you know, really who you talk to. But it's the ability to encode our thoughts, our ideas, concepts in more than one symbolic system and then be able to transmit across time and space
换句话说，我在寻找一个定义。你可以在任何年龄成为双语者，所以你不必从小就会说两种语言才能成为双语者。你可以在儿童期、青春期、成年期甚至老年期学习第二语言。双语者是指能够使用两种语言的人。多语者是指了解并能够使用两种以上语言的人。因此，双语的定义很广，而且这实际上取决于你跟谁交流。但它是将我们的思想、想法、概念编码到不止一个符号系统中，然后能够在时间和空间上传输的能力，
these thoughts, these ideas, and have someone else decode them. So the more symbolic systems you have at your disposal, the more languages you know. What about people who can understand a second language, but they can't actually speak it or they speak a little of it with great difficulty? I'm thinking of this. My mother grew up in an Italian family at a time when you weren't supposed to speak Italian except in the home and they didn't want their kids to speak. Italian, but the kids understood what the parents were saying. Do you get any of the brain benefits of being bilingual if you are in that situation? Yeah, so if you are referring to what's known as heritage bilingualism, bilinguals who grow up in a household where there is a heritage language
这些思想、这些想法，并让其他人对其进行解码。因此，你拥有的符号系统越多，你懂的语言就越多。那些能听懂第二语言但实际上不会说，或者说得很少且非常吃力的人呢？我想到了这一点。我母亲在一个意大利家庭长大的，当时除了家里以外，是不准说意大利语的，他们不希望自己的孩子说意大利语，但孩子们能听懂父母在说什么。如果你处于那种情况，能获得双语带来的任何大脑益处吗？是的，如果你指的是所谓的传承双语（heritage bilingualism），即在传承语言的家庭环境中长大的双语者，
that their parents or grandparents or their previous family generations of their family spoke, that may be different from the dominant language outside the home. And there are many heritage bilinguals in the United States, the extent of their fluency in the two languages varies, but they do indeed show many of the consequences of knowing two languages that children and who grew up with two languages or people who are fluent in both languages show as well. So it's really the type of language experience that you have that can make your bilingual or multilingual. And there are a different. kinds of bilingual and multilinguals.
他们的父母、祖父母或前几代家庭成员所说的语言可能与家门外的优势语言不同。在美国有很多这样的传承双语者，他们在两种语言中的流利程度各不相同，但他们确实表现出了许多了解两种语言所带来的结果，这与从小就会说两种语言的孩子或双语都流利的人所表现出来的相似。所以，真正能让你成为双语或多语者的，是你所拥有的语言经历类型。而且双语者和多语者也有很多不同的类型。
Well, let's talk for a minute about some of the benefits that you researchers have found by studying people who are bilingual or multilingual. What are the kinds of benefits that they experience in the way that they think, in the way that their brain functions and maybe even is structured? Yeah, so one of the most striking and interesting findings in recent years is that people who use two or more languages show and... delayed onset of Alzheimer's and other types of dementia. They are diagnosed on average four to six years later than monolinguals, depending on the
好吧，我们花一分钟时间来谈谈你们研究人员通过研究双语或多语人群发现的一些好处。他们在思维方式、大脑功能甚至结构方面体验到了哪些类型的好处？是的，近年来最引人注目和最有趣的发现之一是，使用两种或多种语言的人表现出……阿尔茨海默病和其他类型痴呆症的发作时间延迟。平均而言，他们的诊断时间比单语者晚四 to 六年，具体取决于你所看的
study that you are looking at. It seems that knowing to homo-languages offer some of those protective benefits against the cognitive decline that's often seen, that's sometimes seen with healthy aging and that's regularly seen with dementia. And not only at the individual level, but at the population level, there are now studies that show that countries in which two or more languages are official languages of the country have a lower incidence of dementia than countries where one language is the official language of the country.
研究。似乎掌握两种或多种语言提供了一些对抗认知衰退的保护性益处，这种认知衰退在健康老化中经常看到（有时看到），并且在痴呆症中经常看到。不仅在个人层面，在人口层面，现在也有研究表明，将两种或多种语言作为国家官方语言的国家，其痴呆症发病率比将一种语言作为国家官方语言的国家要低。
And there is actually a direct correlation between the number of languages spoken in the country in the incidence of Alzheimer's. So it's a really interesting new finding showing that the consequences of being bilingual or multilingual are not only at the level of the individual, but also at the level of society. And actually in my book, The Power of Language, I organize the the book is structured into two parts. The first one talks about the self and then the second one talks about society and how both are changed by knowing two more languages. In the case of dementia, what seems to be happening is that the constant workouts that our brains receive by having to juggle multiple languages is like an exercise for the brain and has this
实际上，一个国家使用的语言数量与痴呆症发病率之间存在直接关联。所以这是一个非常有趣的最新发现，表明双语或多语的后果不仅存在于个人层面，也存在于社会层面。实际上，在我的书《语言的力量》中，我将这本书组织并构建为两个部分。第一部分讨论自我，第二部分讨论社会，以及这两者是如何因掌握两种或更多语言而改变的。在痴呆症的情况下，似乎发生的情况是，我们的大脑因为必须应付多种语言而不断进行锻炼，就像大脑的体操一样，并产生了这些
positive consequences. So one way to describe this is imagine that you have been taking the same bridge or the same road home every day for many years. throughout your life. You go to work, you come home, you take this road. You go to the store, you go to the pharmacy, wherever you're going. You go back and forth. You always take the same road. And then one day when you way back, you discover that that road has collapsed. If that's the only road that exists to your house, then you are in trouble. You won't be able to reach your destination. But if there are multiple roads that have been built over time, if you know those roads, then you simply reroute your car and you are able to reach your destination with no problem.
积极的结果。所以，描述这一点的一种方式是，想象一下你一生中多年来每天都走同一座桥或同一条路回家。你去上班，你回家，你走这条路。你去商店，你去药店，无论你去哪里。你来回走。你总是走同一条路。然后有一天，当你在回家的路上时，你发现那条路已经塌了。如果那是通往你家的唯一道路，那么你就麻烦了。你将无法到达目的地。但如果随着时间推移建造了多条道路，如果你知道这些道路，那么你只需给汽车重新规划路线，就能毫无问题地到达目的地。
In the same way, if there are multiple languages that you've used throughout your life to encode memories, to encode experiences, to learn, to live your life in, you can compensate functionally through using those languages for the anatomical deterioration that your brain experiences. So it's not that the bilingual or multilingual brain doesn't experience deterioration. It does. But people who know normal languages are able to compensate for it functionally and live a health life as if they don't have the same degree of impact for longer.
同理，如果在你的一生中，你曾用多种语言来编码记忆、编码经历、学习并以此生活，那么你可以通过使用这些语言，在功能上补偿大脑经历的解剖学退化。因此，并不是说双语或多语的大脑不会经历退化。它确实会经历。但懂多种语言的人能够在功能上对其进行补偿，并像没有受到同等程度的影响一样，更长时间地过上健康的生活。
And four to six years might not seem like a lot when you are, I don't know, 20, 18, but when you are older four to six years is really a big difference. and can make a difference from being able to play with your grandchildren or never knowing them. And there is nothing else that we know of other than perhaps exercise that has as strong of an effect on a protective effect on cognitive decline and Alzheimer's system and dementia as the effect size of bilingualism and multilingualism. So it's one of the most remarkable recent findings in the field. So exercise is up there, but what about some of these other mentally enriching things that we engage in, such as maybe having more years of education or a challenging hobby? You're saying that being multilingual gives you greater cognitive benefits than those things? Those are all good, and you're right that a level of education is a plus.
而且，当你二十岁、十八岁时，四到六年可能看起来不算什么，但当你年老时，四到六年真的是一个很大的差异，它可能会带来截然不同的结果：是能够和孙子孙女玩耍，还是永远无法认识他们。除了运动之外，我们所知的没有任何其他事物，对认知衰退、阿尔茨海默综合征和痴呆症具有像双语和多语现象那样强大且具保护性的效果。因此，这是该领域近年来最显著的发现之一。所以运动名列前茅，但我们参与的其他一些能丰富精神生活的事情呢，比如接受更多年的教育或培养一个具有挑战性的爱好？你是说，会多门语言带给你的认知益处比这些还要大吗？这些都很好，而且你说的对，受教育程度是一个加分项，
nutrition is a plus, engaging and enriching activities is a plus, all of those things are very good. But based on my review of the literature looking at meta-analysis, it seems like that effect sizes a largest for exercise in bilingualism. And what's really interesting about bilingualism and multilingualism is that you don't have to take time out of your life to engage in those. to see benefits. So for example, we know that engaging in cognitively enriching benefits, cognitively enriching activities like Sudoku or word puzzles or math, just any kind of cognitively challenging activity is beneficial for the brain. And it's a good thing to do as we age for our cognitive health. But for all of those, you have to actively take time out of your life to do those things, whether it's reading, and of course, reading is wonderful for you,
营养是一个加分项，参与丰富活动是一个加分项，所有这些都非常好。但根据我对观察元分析的文献的回顾，似乎运动和双语的效果量是最大的。双语和多语真正有趣的地方在于，你不需要占用生活中的时间去参与这些活动，就能看到益处。例如，我们知道参与丰富认知的活动，比如数独、字谜或数学，任何具有认知挑战性的活动对大脑都是有益的。随着年龄的增长，这对我们的认知健康是一件好事。但对于所有这些，你都必须主动抽出时间去做这些事情，无论是阅读（当然，阅读对你大有裨益），
whether it's doing puzzles, that's all great. But with being bilingual and multilingual, you simply go about your life using one language or another, and you are constantly giving your brain a workout, because your brain has to facilitate the language you are using and inhibit the language you're not using and sort of control the languages you're using at any given time. For example, you and I right now speaking in English, our brains have to control our output. It would do us little good if I suddenly would switch to Spanish or French or Romanian or Russian. So I have to make sure that I control those. I inhibit those and I facilitate just English. And you do this all the time, whether you are reading, you know, a road sign, you're listening to a movie, a song, you're speaking with someone,
无论是做拼图，这些都很棒。但通过成为双语和多语者，你只需过着你的日常生活，使用一种或另一种语言，并且你一直在给你的大脑进行锻炼，因为你的大脑必须促进你正在使用的语言，同时抑制你没有使用的语言，并且在任何给定时间控制你正在使用的语言。例如，你和我现在用英语交谈，我们的大脑必须控制我们的输出。如果我突然切换到西班牙语、法语、罗马尼亚语或俄语，对我们没有什么好处。所以我必须确保我控制住它们。我抑制它们，只促进英语。无论你是在阅读路标、听电影、歌曲、还是与人交谈，你一直在这样做，
you're constantly juggling your many languages. So this constant experience juggling different languages seems to be having an effect on your executive function that later translates to benefits beyond just language. And I have to say that this area of research, not the dementia part, but the executive function part is somewhat controversial. Not all studies find benefits of bilingualism on executive function. And sometimes people up in arms about that. I am not up in arms about that and I can tell you why. The reason I'm not up in arms about that is because bilingual experience varies. There are different kinds of bilingualism. Executive function is an umbrella term that includes multiple components. So I think asking the question in this absolute ways, does bilingualism
你一直在应付你的多种语言。因此，这种应付不同语言的持续体验似乎对你的执行功能产生了影响，这种影响后来转化为超越纯粹语言的好处。我必须说，这一研究领域，不是痴呆部分，而是执行功能部分，是有一定争议的。并非所有研究都发现双语对执行功能有好处。有时人们对此争论不休。我并没有为此争论不休，我可以告诉你为什么。我之所以不争论不休，是因为双语体验是多样化的。存在不同类型的双语。执行功能是一个总括性术语，包括多个组成部分。因此，用这种绝对的方式提出问题：双语是否
benefit executive function or not? This black or white approach is not the right way to look at things. A better question would be to ask what aspect, what kinds of language experience, influence what kind of executive function and under what circumstance. It's sort of like thinking about exercise. I think universally everyone knows that exercise is good for you. We agree that exercise is good for your health and for aging. But it's not like every single type of exercise you do will benefit every single type of your health
有利于执行功能？这种非黑即白的态度并不是看待事物的正确方式。更好的问题应该是：在什么情况下，什么方面、什么样的语言经验会影响哪种执行功能？这有点像思考运动。我认为每个人都普遍知道运动对你有好处。我们都赞同运动对健康和抗衰老有益。但并不是你做的每一种类型的运动都会对你的每一类健康产生益处，
under every single kind of amounts and duration. And there are just so many other variables. Some things benefit. Some variables, others benefit other variables. So taking this absolute black and white approach is really not a good way to do science. I know that we all like simplify yes, no answers, but it's a much more nuanced, nuanced, complicated issue. I want to talk for a minute about what goes on in the brains of people who know multiple languages. Are all of the languages you know always active or is your brain shutting off and sectioning things so that you know that we're speaking English right now?
也不论任何数量和时长。而且还有太多的其他变量。有些事情使某些变量受益，另一些事情使其他变量受益。因此，采取这种绝对的黑白分明的方法真的不是做科学的好方法。我知道我们都喜欢简化的“是”、“否”答案，但这是一个更加细致入微、复杂的问题。我想花一分钟时间来谈谈懂多种语言的人的大脑中发生了什么。你懂的所有语言是一直都处于活跃状态，还是你的大脑在关闭和分段，以便让你知道我们现在在说英语？
you're not going to slip into Romanian by accident. Yeah, we used to think that people switch between languages. There was this language switch hypothesis where there was the belief that when you use one language, you're using it, then you're done with it, then you switch it off, you switch the other one on, you use that other language. And there's also the belief that different languages are represented in different parts of the brain. So you have like a place for English, a place for fringe, a place for Hebrew, place for Arabic, whatever language you are using. We now know that's not the case. We know that
你不会不小心溜出罗马尼亚语。是的，我们过去认为人们会在语言之间切换。存在这样一种语言切换假说，即人们认为当你使用一种语言时，你正在使用它，然后你用完了，然后你把它关掉，你打开另一语言，你使用那另一种语言。人们还认为不同的语言在大脑的不同部分中呈现。所以你有一个存放英语的地方、一个存放法语的地方、一个存放希伯来语的地方、一个存放阿拉伯语的地方，无论你使用的是什么语言。我们现在知道并非如此。我们知道
language is distributed throughout multiple areas of the brain. It's a network. And we also know that we don't ever really switch off our languages. They are constantly co-activated and running in parallel. So our brain is this very impressive superorganisms that processes information in parallel at all times from multiple modalities. And we know this through multiple lines of research, including research that uses eye tracking that shows that people who speak multiple languages, when they hear a word in one language, they often make eye movements to objects in their visual display, in their visual scene, that sounds similar in another language.
语言分布在大脑的多个区域。它是一个网络。而且我们也知道，我们从未真正关闭过我们的语言。它们一直在被共同激活并并行运行。因此，我们的大脑是一个非常令人印象深刻的超级有机体，它始终通过多种模态并行处理信息。我们通过多条研究路线知道了这一点，包括使用眼动追踪的研究，这些研究表明，说多种语言的人，当他们听到一种语言中的一个词时，他们经常会将视线移动到视觉显示中听起来像另一种语言的物体上，即他们的视觉场景中。
So, for example, if you're an English speaker, and I see you in front of a little, a bunch of objects on the desk, and I tell you to pick up a marker while recording your eye movements, as you pick up the marker, you will often make eye movements to other objects, like marbles, for example, that start with the same word onset, like marker and marbles. But if you speak Spanish, you'll make eye movements to other objects that start with the same onset in your language, like a butterfly. The Spanish word for butterfly is mariposa. If you speak Russian, you may make eye movements or you do make eye movements to a stamp because the Russian word for stamp is marker. So as you hear, marker, you make eye movements to a stamp.
例如，如果你是一个英语使用者，我看到你面前有一小堆桌子上的物体，我让你在记录你的眼球运动的同时拿起一个马克笔，当你拿起马克笔时，你经常会把眼球运动投向其他物体，例如大理石（marbles），它们以相同的词首开头，如 marker 和 marbles。但如果你说西班牙语，你就会将眼球运动投向用你的语言中以相同词首开头的其他物体，比如蝴蝶。西班牙语中的蝴蝶是 mariposa。如果你说俄语，你可能会将眼球运动投向邮票，因为俄语中的邮票是 marker。所以当你听到 marker 时，你就会把眼球运动投向邮票。
So people who speak different languages make eye movements towards different objects as they hear language. Different objects in their visual scene attract their attention. And we are now even finding that they remember what they had seen differently, depending on the language. which is they speak. So if you ask a Russian speaker, they are much more likely to remember that there was a stamp on that desk when they were looking for a marker
因此，说不同语言的人在听到语言时会将眼球运动投向不同的物体。他们视觉场景中的不同物体吸引了他们的注意力。而且我们现在甚至发现，根据他们所说的语言，他们对所见事物的记忆方式也有所不同。
than an English monolingual speaker. And the Spanish speaker is more likely to remember that they saw a butterfly flying around when they were looking for a marker than if you don't speak Spanish. It's really interesting because it shows us that the languages we speak influence what we see,
所以如果你问一个俄语使用者，当他们在寻找马克笔时，他们更有可能记住那张桌子上有一枚邮票，
our perception of the world around us, our perception of reality and influences what we remember later when we think about our environment. So think back to experiences we've had. So language is this very powerful experience that we filter our world through and our lives through. Your summer starts now with Memorial Day deals at the Home Depot. It's time to fire up summer cookouts with the next grill, four-burner gas grill, on special buy for only $190.190. and entertain all season with the Hampton Bay West Grove
而英语单语使用者则不然。而西班牙语使用者更有可能记住，当他们在寻找马克笔时，他们看到一只蝴蝶在飞，而不说西班牙语的人则不会这样。这真的很有趣，因为它向我们表明，我们所说的语言会影响我们所看到的东西，
seven-piece outdoor dining set for only $499. This Memorial Day get low prices guaranteed at the Home Depot. While supplies last, price invalid May 14th or May 27th, U.S. only exclusions apply. See Home Depot.com slash price match for details. You said this place was steps from the water.
我们对周围世界的感知、我们对现实的感知，并会影响我们后来在思考周围环境时的记忆。所以回想一下我们所经历的经验。因此，语言是一个非常强大的体验，我们通过它来过滤我们的世界和我们的生活。现在在家得宝 (The Home Depot) 购买阵亡将士纪念日特惠商品，开启您的夏日之旅。是时候用 Nextgrill 四火眼燃气烤炉燃起夏日烧烤了，特价仅售 190 美元。
We just haven't found the steps yet. How much did we save? Enough. Enough to get lost. Or you got to be. book a stay with Hilton. Welcome to your oceanfront room. Just steps from the water. The Hilton sale is on now. Book on Hilton.com or the Hilton app and save up to 20% to get the stay you expected. When you want savings, not surprises. It matters where you stay. Hilton, for the stay.
用 Hampton Bay West Grove 七件套户外餐桌椅尽情招待整个季节，仅售 499 美元。这个阵亡将士纪念日，在家得宝享受保证低价。售完即止，价格有效期为 5 月 14 日或 5 月 27 日，仅限美国，不适用于某些情况。详情请访问 Homedepot.com/pricematch。你曾说过这个地方离水边只有几步之遥。
If you grow up in a bilingual household, at what point do you realize that there are two different languages being spoken instead of one big language that encompasses both? That's a good question because it taps into what's known as metalinguistic ability. Mental linguistic ability is the ability to reason about language abstractly. And we all as adults develop it eventually. So adults know that you can call something, but by any word you want, and it doesn't change what this word is, I might have a pan and I might call it a pan or a ruchka or a stilow or however. call it, and it doesn't change it. But bilingual kids develop this ability to reason about
我们只是还没找到那些台阶。我们省了多少钱？够了。够多到迷路了。或者说你必须去。预订希尔顿的住宿。欢迎来到您的海滨房间。离水边仅几步之遥。希尔顿促销活动正在进行中。在 Hilton.com 或希尔顿应用程序上预订，最高可省 20%，获得您期望的住宿体验。当您想要省钱而不是惊喜时。您住哪里很重要。希尔顿，伴您好梦。
objects and their names in this abstract ways earlier than monolingual kids. At an early age, they understand that the world and the words we used to refer to the world are not one and the same, that you can change the labels and it doesn't change the object. So this is really a foundational, skillful cognitive development, being able to reason abstractly about. our environment and the labels we used to refer to it. In your book, you write about how for people who are bilingual, the experience of speaking in their native versus their non-native language may be quite different. For example, people may make different moral decisions or access different memories when they're talking in their native versus their non-native language. Can you talk about that?
如果你在双语家庭中长大，在哪个时刻你意识到有两种不同的语言在被说，而不是一种包含两者的宏大语言？这是一个很好的问题，因为它触及了所谓的元语言能力（metalinguistic ability）。元语言能力是抽象推理语言的能力。我们成年人最终都会培养出这种能力。所以成年人知道你可以用任何你想要的词来称呼某物，但这并不会改变这个词是什么，我可能有一个平底锅，我可能叫它平底锅（pan）或 ruchka 或 stilow 或随你叫它什么，这并没有改变它。但双语儿童比单语儿童更早地培养出以这种抽象方式对物体及其名称进行推理的能力。在很小的时候，他们就明白世界和我们用来指代世界的词汇并不是同一回事，你可以改变标签而不会改变物体。因此，这确实是一项基础的、巧妙的认知发展，能够对我们的环境和我们用来指代它的标签进行抽象推理。在你的书中，你写道，对于双语者来说，用母语和非母语说话的体验可能大不相同。例如，人们在用母语和非母语交谈时，可能会做出不同的道德决策或调用不同的记忆。你能谈谈这个吗？
What are the connections among language, memory, and emotion that are all at play? This is a really rich topic because it does make a big difference in our decision-making and the emotions we feel in how we think about our identity and how we interact with others, depending on which language we are speaking at any given time. There is some evidence suggesting that the native language tends to be a more emotional language, tends to be tied to emotions more closely, whereas the second language often can be a more logical language or lead to people making decisions that are more logical and utilitarian. So in one of this areas of research, scientists were asking bilinguals to make moral decisions in either they are native language or their second language. And I'll give you an example.
语言、记忆和情感之间有哪些相互作用的联系？这是一个非常丰富的话题，因为它确实对我们的决策、我们的情感、我们对自我身份的思考以及我们与他人的互动产生了重大影响，这取决于我们在任何给定时间所使用的语言。有一些证据表明，母语往往是一种更具情感色彩的语言，与情感的联系更紧密，而第二语言通常可以是一种更符合逻辑的语言，或者会导致人们做出更符合逻辑和功利主义的决策。因此，在这一研究领域之一中，科学家要求双语者用他们的母语或第二语言做出道德决策。我给你举个例子。
You may have heard of the very famous Strolley Dilemma. And there are different versions of it. But in this particular version of the trolley dilemma, a trolley is coming down the tracks, and there are five workers working on the tracks, and the trolley is about to run over them and kill them. And you are standing on the footbridge above those tracks next to a large person with a large backpack, and if you push the person off the footbridge, the person will die, but that will stop the trolley and will save the lives of these five people. So the question is, is it permissible to sacrifice the life of one person to save the lives of five people?
你可能听说过非常著名的电车难题（Trolley Dilemma）。它有不同的版本。但在电车难题的这个特定版本中，一辆电车顺着铁轨驶来，有五个工人在铁轨上工作，电车即将碾压并杀死他们。你正站在这些铁轨上方的行人天桥上，旁边有一个背着大背包的大块头，如果你把这个人从行人天桥上推下去，这个人就会死，但这会阻止电车并拯救这五个人的生命。所以问题是，牺牲一个人的生命来拯救五个人的生命是否是允许的？
How would you answer that? I hate that dilemma. I don't know what I would do. I think I would not be able to push somebody off a bridge. I hate the dilemma too. And I know what you mean. And your answer is being it. It really just depends.
你会怎么回答？我讨厌那个难题。我不知道我会怎么做。我想我无法把某人从桥上推下去。我也讨厌这个难题。我明白你的意思。你的回答是。这真的取决于情况。
You can change. A lot of people would say, yeah, I can see how it makes more sense to sacrifice one person for five, but I would never push a person off the bridge or kill a person. Some people would be more likely to do it if all they have to do is push a button versus push a person. And then it depends if it's five people versus 5,000 people. There are so many versions of this problem. But interestingly, it seems that if you ask bilinguals to make this decision in their native language versus their second language, you see differences in how they answer.
你可以改变。很多人会说，是的，我能理解为什么为一个牺牲一个人对五个人更有意义，但我永远不会把一个人推下桥或杀死一个人。如果他们所要做的只是按下一个按钮而不是推一个人，有些人更有可能这样做。然后这取决于它是五个人还是五千个人。这个问题有太多的版本。但有趣的是，如果你要求双语者用他们的母语与第二语言来做这个决定，你会发现他们的回答方式存在差异。
They are much more likely to be guided. by what's known as deontological value, so what's inherently morally right or wrong in their native language and say that they are less likely to sacrifice the life, to kill one person, to sacrifice the life of one person for five
他们更有可能受到被称为道义论价值（deontological value）的引导，即在他们的母语中什么是内在的道德对错，并表示他们不太可能为了五个人而牺牲一个人的生命、去杀死一个人、
when they're speaking their native language versus when they're speaking their second language. When they're speaking their second language, they are more likely to make a utilitarian decision and decide that you go with a decision that has the greater good. So this is one set of experiments, but people have looked at the likelihood of cheating,
当他们说母语时，与他们说第二语言时相比。当他们说第二语言时，他们更有可能做出功利主义的决定，并决定选择带来更大善意的决定。所以这是一组实验，但人们也研究了作弊的可能性、
at medical decisions, at all sorts of decisions, and they're finding that bilingual tend to make different decisions in one language versus another. And it does seem that the first language just tends to be more closely tied to emotions. And I think many individuals who speak to more languages often experience at themselves, that they feel, a different reaction when someone says, I love you to them in their native language. Or when they say themselves in their native language versus their second language.
医疗决策以及各种决策，他们发现双语者倾向于在一种语言与另一种语言中做出不同的决定。而且第一语言确实似乎与情感有着更紧密的联系。我认为许多会说两种或多种语言的人自己也经常体验到这一点，当有人用他们的母语对他们说“我爱你”时，他们会感觉到一种不同的反应。或者当他们用母语而不是第二语言对自己说时。
So that's a tip out there for your listeners who may be in the relationships with bilinguals or multilinguals, to learn some of these key phrases, emotional phrases, in the native language of the person you are in a relationship with to help build a deeper connection. And it's also curse words. people where bilingual differ in their likelihood of being able to curse or how worked up they get when they hear curse words in their native language versus second language. Many bilinguals, myself included, will tell you that they could never curse in certain, you know, powerfully in a native language and have no problem doing that in their second, third, fourth language where you don't have just such strong connections and emotional reactions.
所以这是一个给你们听众的小贴士，他们可能与双语者或多语者处于恋爱关系中，去学习一些关键短语，即情感短语，用你交往之人的母语，来帮助建立更深层次的联系。这也是脏话。双语者在用母语与第二语言说脏话或听到脏话时的激动程度方面有所不同。许多双语者，包括我自己，会告诉你，他们永远无法在某种程度上用母语粗俗地骂人，但在他们的第二、第三、第四语言中却没有问题，因为在这些语言中你没有那么强的联系和情感反应。
So there is this relationship between the language you speak and how you feel, what you remember, the emotion. It's just we could talk about this for so long because there is just so much interesting research on this topic. And I go into a lot of it in the book, but I'm happy to talk about some of the examples here. I want to ask something a little bit out of left field maybe. We did a podcast not that long ago about people who can speak dozens of languages. And I'm wondering in all the research you have done, is there a limit to the number of languages that a human brain can learn? Not that we know of. And I think this is one of the reasons why I'm so interested in multilingualism.
因此，你所说的语言与你的感受、你的记忆、你的情感之间存在着这种关系。只是我们可以讨论这么长时间，因为关于这个话题有太多有趣的研究。我在书里探讨了很多内容，但我很高兴在这里谈论一些例子。我想问一个可能有点意料之外的问题。不久前我们做过一期播客，关于那些能说几十种语言的人。我想知道在你们所做的所有研究中，人类大脑能够学习的语言数量是否有上限？据我们所知没有。我认为这也是为什么我对多语现象如此感兴趣的原因之一。
At the core of it, I'm interested in language and thought, language and mind, how close. closely related language and thought are, what does language learning tell us about learning in general? Because there does seem to be a relationship between, you know, with each new language you learn, it becomes easier to learn additional language. So it's this virtual cycle. The more you learn, the easier it becomes to learn more things in languages. So there are indeed multilinguals who speak 2, 6, 20 there have been
核心在于，我对语言与思想、语言与心灵感兴趣，语言和思想的联系有多紧密，语言学习能告诉我们关于一般学习的什么信息？因为每学习一门新语言，学习其他语言似乎就会变得更容易，这两者之间似乎确实存在着一种关系。所以这是一个良性循环。你学得越多，学习语言中的更多东西就变得越容易。因此，确实有多语者会说 2 种、6 种、20 种语言，甚至有人声称
claims of over 100 languages and it of course also depends on what you define as a language and what you define as fluency but the human mind seems to be able to learn
会说 100 多种语言，当然这还取决于你如何定义语言以及你如何定义流利程度，但人类的心智似乎真的能够无限期地学习语言，
languages at infinitum really and it's really interesting to compare artificial intelligence and human intelligence and use multilingualism as a way to study the human potential. What is language, if I can ask that? How do you define it? Is computer code language? Is math language? Is music language? I'm glad you asked it because I think most people use a definitional language in a somewhat narrower sense than I tend to think about it. So usually when more Most people, when they think about language, they think about natural languages like English or Spanish or French or Hindi, a language that a group of people speaks and communicates and all sign language.
并将人工智能与人类智能进行比较，并以多语现象作为研究人类潜力的一种方式。如果我可以这样问的话，什么是语言？你是如何定义它的？计算机代码是语言吗？数学是语言吗？音乐是语言吗？我很高兴你问了这个问题，因为我认为大多数人对语言的定义的理解比我倾向于思考的要窄一些。所以通常大多数人在想到语言时，他们会想到自然语言，如英语、西班牙语、法语、印地语，即一群人说和交流的语言，以及所有手语。
If we broaden the definition of language to use it to refer to a symbolic system. So language is something that uses symbols to communicate information. Then we can go beyond this natural human languages. And it is an apt definition because as we mentioned earlier, what languages do is they use symbols, words, or notations, to encode the thought and idea, a concept transmitted over space and time for someone at the other end or something at the other end, decoded. And if we use that broader definition, they're not just natural languages,
如果我们把语言的定义扩大到指代一个符号系统。因此，语言是使用符号来传输出信息的某种东西。那么我们就可以超越这些人类的自然语言。这是一个恰当的定义，因为正如我们前面提到的，语言的作用是使用符号、词汇或符号来编码思想、想法、概念，并在空间和时间内传输，以便让另一端的某人或另一端的某物进行解码。如果我们使用那个更宽泛的定义，它们不仅是自然语言，
they're not just sign languages, which are also natural languages, but also computer languages, artificial languages, math, music can also be conceived of as symbolic systems, as languages. And many will tell you that math is a language. That's one of the most powerful languages out there. Math is as the queen of sciences that allows us to encode really complex ideas that have allowed humanity to
它们不仅是手语（这也是自然语言），而且计算机语言、人工语言、数学、音乐也可以被视为符号系统，被视为语言。许多人会告诉你，数学是一种语言。那是现存最强大的语言之一。数学是科学的女王，它使我们能够编码非常复杂的思想，使人类能够
make discoveries and build things that we wouldn't be able to do without math. So, if we broaden the definition of language to symbolic systems and most of our minds, even if we only speak one natural language, human natural language,
做出没有数学就无法做到的小发现和建造事物。因此，如果我们把语言的定义扩大到符号系统，我们大多数人的心灵，即使我们只会说一种自然语言——人类自然语言，
have multiple symbolic systems at our disposal because we can read math and use math. Perhaps we can read music. And each of those symbolic systems changes the way we think. If you have math and you can reason about very big numbers that we couldn't reason about centuries ago, or you have very small numbers, again, you can use math and length and language to now talk about things that I cannot see and create mental concepts that you would not be able to create otherwise.
我们手头也有多个符号系统，因为我们可以阅读数学并使用数学。也许我们可以阅读音乐。这些符号系统中的每一个都改变了我们的思维方式。如果你懂数学，并且能够对几个世纪前我们无法推理的非常大的数字进行推理，或者你有非常小的数字，同样，你也可以使用数学、长度和语言来谈论我看不见的事物，并创造出你否则无法创造的精神概念。
So language is key to scientific discovery, to thought, to technology, to science, to human advancement. It's one of the most powerful tools we have at our disposal. We all know that it's easy or easier for kids to pick up a language compared to adults. But can a person learn a language fluently at any age? We used to think that there is this critical age period. And if you miss that critical age period, too bad. You won't be able to learn a language. And you won't be able to learn a second or third language.
因此，语言是科学发现、思想、技术、科学和人类进步的关键。它是我们手头最强大的工具之一。我们都知道，孩子们比成年人更容易上手一门语言。但是一个人能在任何年龄流利地学习一门语言吗？我们过去认为存在这样一个关键年龄段。如果你错过了那个关键年龄段，那就太糟糕了。你将无法学习语言。而且你将无法学习第二或第三语言。
That turns out not to be the case. you can learn a second language and you can or third or multiple languages, and you can learn them to fluency at any age. Now, you may have an accent if you learn your second or third language later in life after puberty after your articulatory system is set. Not always, some people don't have accents, but many do. You can hear me speak with an accent in English,
事实证明并非如此。你可以学习第二语言，你可以或者第三种语言或多种语言，并且你可以在任何年龄将它们学到流利。现在，如果你在青春期之后、在你的发音系统定型之后在晚年学习第二或第三语言，你可能会有口音。并非总是如此，有些人没有口音，但许多人有。你可以听到我带着英语口音说话，
even though I would consider myself fluent in English. I do have an accent because I learned English later in life. but I'm fluent in it. And you can learn a language to fluency at any age. But even if you don't learn a language to fluency, I would almost say it helps to remove that pressure of yourself and say, well, I can't be fluent. I will always have an accent.
尽管我认为自己的英语已经很流利了。但我有口音，因为我是后来才学会英语的。不过我很流利。而且你在任何年龄都可以把一门语言学到流利。但即使你没有把一门语言学到流利，我几乎可以说，这有助于消除你心中的压力，告诉自己，好吧，我不可能流利，我永远都会有口音。
I'll never be fluent in another language. So maybe I shouldn't even bother. I think that's the wrong approach. You can see a lot of the consequences and benefits of learning another language, even without being fluent. And most of all, it can actually improve your quality of life in many different ways depending on how you choose to learn another language. But if you choose to learn another language by engaging in activities that you enjoy,
我永远不可能在另一门语言中流利。所以也许我甚至不应该费心。我认为这是错误的方法。你可以看到学习另一语言的许多后果和好处，即使并不流利。最重要的是，根据你选择学习另一语言的方式，它实际上可以通过许多不同的方式提高你的生活质量。但如果你选择通过从事你喜欢、
that bring you pleasure and joy and enrich your life and you find a way to learn another language, it makes you happy, be it by exchanging language lessons with another person. And we know that social interaction is so beneficial for mental health, physical health has a lot of positive consequences, or by immersion, by traveling and living in another country, and you enjoy that, then the quality of your life will be improved by that. Or maybe you enjoy learning it using apps. And many of the apps right now capitalize on the knowledge we have from neuroscience by having this reward circuit and the brain activated, all the serotonian and you play this game and you get a reward of some sort where it's a badge
能给你带来快乐和喜悦并丰富你生活、同时找到学习另一语言方法的方式，这会让你感到快乐，无论是与另一个人交流语言课程——我们知道社交互动对心理健康、身体健康非常有益，有许多积极的后果——还是通过沉浸式学习、去另一个国家旅游和生活，如果你喜欢这样，你的生活质量就会因此得到改善。或者也许你喜欢使用应用程序来学习。现在的许多应用程序都在利用我们从神经科学中获得的知识，激活大脑中的这种奖励回路和所有的血清素，你玩这个游戏，并获得某种奖励，比如一枚徽章
or a sound and you move through levels and you enjoy doing that. So whatever it is, maybe you enjoy listening to music in another language or watching a movie in another language. So there are so many reasons to learn another language that may make your life more enjoyable and better that even if you don't become fluent is worthwhile. I want to talk for a minute about an op-ed that you wrote that was published in the Washington Post not long ago that talked about how artificial intelligence may decrease language diversity and multilingualism in the future. Why do you believe that? So I will pull back by saying that most artificial intelligence that is now making the news as it is so much.
或一个声音，你在关卡中穿行，并且乐在其中。所以无论它是什么，也许你喜欢听另一种语言的音乐或看另一语言的电影。因此，学习另一语言有如此多的理由可以让你的生活更愉快、更好，以至于即使你没有变得流利，也是值得的。我想花一分钟时间谈谈你不久前在《华盛顿邮报》上发表的一篇专栏文章，文章谈到了人工智能未来可能会减少语言多样性和多语言现象。你为什么会这么认为？所以我先退一步说，现在成为新闻热点、引起广泛关注的大多数人工智能，
realize what's known as large language models. And these large language models follow the same principles that linguists and psycholinguists, psychologists of language, have been studying for decades. I don't think that many people anticipated that the advancement of this large language models will happen as fast as it has and that they will be able to do as much as they can right now already based on essentially learning and using statistical probabilities and their input at the base. But now that AI is there and it's developing so rapidly and we have this evolution of AI, evolution of knowledge, at a very rapid pace faster than previous generations, it's everyone's
实现了被称为大语言模型的概念。而这些大语言模型遵循着语言学家、心理语言学家以及语言心理学家几十年来一直在研究的相同的原则。我认为很多人并没有预料到这些大语言模型的进步会发生得如此之快，而且它们现在就已经能够做这么多的事情了，这基本上是基于学习和使用底层的统计概率及其输入。但现在人工智能已经出现，并且发展如此迅速，我们经历了人工智能的演变、知识的演变，其速度比前几代人快得多，每个人都在
guess what will happen next. And people vary in the predictions. make. And their predictions are informed on based on their knowledge, if you're a computer scientist, if you're a learning theorist, I'm a psycholinguist. So my predictions are based on what I know about language. And what I will say to that is that our initial predictions, my initial expectation and reaction would be to think that having this LLMs will be beneficial to language diversity because we think, well, now we can. use online translation tools. It can immediately translate text. It can translate language input. Here's my phone. And I can speak into it and will immediately translate when I'm traveling into
猜测接下来会发生什么。人们的预测各不相同。他们的预测基于他们的知识，如果你是计算机科学家，如果你是学习理论家，我是一名心理语言学家。所以我的预测是基于我对语言的了解。我要说的是，我们最初的预测，我最初的期望和反应会认为拥有这些大语言模型将有利于语言多样性，因为我们认为，现在我们可以使用在线翻译工具了。它可以立即翻译文本。它可以翻译语言输入。这是我的手机。当我旅行时，对着它说话，它就能立即翻译成
the language of my listener. So these are all wonderful things and certainly great benefits. You can also now document, record, and save many languages that are dying. So the initial thought is that it will be beneficial. And we do have those. beneficial components. But I think long term, my prognosis for the diversity of natural languages as a result of AI is grim. And here's why. There are more than 7,000 languages spoken in the world today. We lose a few every year. In theory, you could have LLMs, you could have large language models based on all of these 7,000 plus natural languages. However, the way LLM's work is they learn based on the digital footprint that the language
听众的语言。所以这些都是美妙的事情，当然也是巨大的好处。你现在还可以记录、录制和保存许多正在消亡的语言。所以最初的想法是它将是有益的。我们确实拥有这些有益的成分。但我认为从长远来看，由于人工智能的影响，我对自然语言多样性的预测是严峻的。原因如下。当今世界上使用的语言超过7000种。我们每年都会失去几种。理论上，你可以拥有大语言模型，你可以基于这7000多种自然语言构建大语言模型。然而，大语言模型的工作方式是它们基于语言在网上的
has online. So the more information, the larger the database that exists online, the better those language models will be. And we do have a huge linguistic footprint in English, in Mandarin, in French, in several languages. So those models learn on a much larger input, and therefore, they become better than large language models that learn on a much more limited input. And predictions vary on how many LLMs are likely to become really powerful. Some conservative estimates are at around 20, but even if we broaden it from 20 to, let's say, 200 or, or 2000.
数字足迹进行学习。因此，在线存在的信息越多、数据库越大，那些语言模型就会越好。我们在英语、普通话、法语以及其他几种语言中拥有巨大的语言足迹。因此，这些模型基于更大的输入进行学习，因此它们变得比基于更有限输入进行学习的大语言模型更好。对于可能变得真正强大大语言模型的数量，预测各不相同。一些保守的估计在20个左右，但即使我们将范围从20扩大到，比如说，200或2000。
It's not realistic to think 2000, but that's still not 7,000 plus. So most likely, only a very small relatively to the 7,000 plus languages will have a large enough
认为有2000个是不现实的，但这仍然不是7000多种。因此，相对于7000多种语言而言，很可能只有极少数语言
digital footprint to result in very good, strong LLM's language models. And you can think of this almost as an invasive species that then drives out the smaller language And of course, we're not talking about tomorrow or a year from now. We are talking about perhaps a few generations, but, and this is, and some might say much
会拥有足够大的数字预算，从而产生非常好的、强大的人工智能语言模型。你可以把这几乎看作是一种入侵物种，它随后排挤了较小的语言。当然，我们谈论的不是明天或一年后。我们谈论的可能是几代人之后，但，这就是，有些人可能会说得多得多
less than a few generation. It remains to be seen because human nature is such that we will always want to use the best, the strongest, so we'll always want to use the best model out there. So eventually a few models will win out. So if we push this argument really further, almost to the like a science fiction film direction, you can imagine a situation where a lot of the small languages are disappearing at a much faster pace. And if language and thought are indeed interconnected with this many languages dying out, we lose some diversity of thought.
比几代人还要少。这还有待观察，因为人性就是这样，我们总是想使用最好、最强大的东西，所以我们总是想使用现有的最佳模型。因此，最终少数模型将会胜出。如果我们把这个论点进一步推向极限，几乎朝着科幻电影的方向发展，你可以想象这样一种情况：许多小语言正以快得多的速度消失。如果语言和思想确实是相互联系的，随着这么多语言的消亡，我们失去了一些思想的多样性。
We use the cultures, the concept, the differences. and the way people think as a result of these dying languages. So we will simultaneously potentially have two competing things happening at the same time. Diversity of languages, natural languages disappearing, diversity of human thought disappearing, maybe having more uniform thinking as a result of only several large LLMs, while at the same time as the decreased diversity of languages and thought, the artificial languages, and artificial intelligence continues to evolve and becomes stronger.
由于这些正在消亡的语言，我们失去了文化、概念、差异以及人们思考的方式。因此，我们可能会同时看到两件相互竞争的事情同时发生：自然语言的多样性消失了，人类思想的多样性消失了，由于只有几个大型大语言模型，可能会产生更统一的思考，而与此同时，随着语言和思想多样性的减少，人工语言和人工智能继续演变并变得更强大。
And that's not a great scenario to think about for us humans. Now, we don't know what will happen. Things can go very different ways right now. In just this past week, very recently the European Union started putting some guidelines in place on artificial intelligence. I'm sure that, most other countries will follow, but it's very difficult, if not impossible, to regulate AI in this kind of research. It doesn't take a lot to have a rotation or an individual group of individuals
这对我们人类来说并不是一个很好的思考场景。现在，我们不知道会发生什么。事情现在可能会朝着截然不同的方向发展。就在过去的一周里，最近欧盟开始对人工智能制定一些指导方针。我相信大多数其他国家也会效仿，但在这种研究中规范人工智能是非常困难的，甚至是不可能的。不需要太多努力就会出现一个轮换或个别的个人群体
to really not want to follow those regulations. So we are on the precipice of big changes in the evolution of knowledge. And I think the psychology of language is likely to play an important role. It almost makes me think of the movie arrival on how important the ability to communicate is for humanity. One last question to wrap up. What are the big questions you're looking at now? What would you like to be able to answer in the next six months or a year?
真的不想遵守这些规定。因此，我们正处于知识演变巨大变革的边缘。我认为语言心理学很可能会扮演重要角色。这几乎让我想起了电影《降临》，其中交流的能力对人类来说是多么重要。最后一个要总结的问题。你现在正在关注哪些重大问题？在接下来的六个月或一年里，你希望能够回答什么问题？
We have about a dozen experiments in the lab right now. So for the past more than 20 years, I've been looking at coactivation and parallel processing of languages and bilinguals and multilinguals. And now I'm looking at the consequences of parallel processing for higher level cognition, for higher level cognitive processes like memory, like creativity, like decision making, like semantic organization. So does the fact that our mind processes, multiple languages and parallel changes how? higher level cognition. So I just mentioned the memory study that was just published in science advances this year showing that people who speak different languages remember different things. So now we are looking at the consequences for creativity, decision making. We're also looking at the relationship between form and meaning. So is it completely arbitrary, the form of words and
我们目前在实验室里有大约十几个实验。在过去的20多年里，我一直在研究双语者和多语者语言的共激活和并行处理。现在我正在研究并行处理对高级认知、高级认知过程（如记忆、创造力、决策、语义组织）的后果。那么，我们的大脑处理多种语言和并行处理这一事实是否改变了高级认知？我刚才提到的记忆研究今年刚刚在《科学进展》上发表，表明说不同语言的人会记住不同的事情。所以现在我们正在研究对创造力、决策制定的影响。我们还在研究形式与意义之间的关系。那么，词语的形式是完全任意的吗？
the meaning they carry, which tells us about the relationship between language and thought. And this is another question that has been around for centuries. We're looking at, we have a study right now on parent children and parents and children in different countries who are bilingual. And we are finding that parents and children, toddlers, young children, four-year-olds and their moms, interact with each other differently depending upon which language they speak. So as early as a preschool age, children interact differently with their caregivers and the caregivers interact differently with the children depending on the languages that they speak. So we have multiple projects in the lab.
它们所承载的意义，告诉我们语言和思想之间的关系。这也是一个存在了几个世纪的另一个问题。我们正在研究，我们目前有一项关于不同国家父母和孩子、双语父母和孩子的的研究。我们发现，父母和孩子、幼儿、年幼的儿童、四岁的孩子和他们的妈妈，根据他们所说的语言，彼此互动的方式有所不同。因此，早在学龄前阶段，根据他们所说的语言，儿童与照顾者的互动方式不同，照顾者与儿童的互动方式也不同。所以我们的实验室有多个项目。
We're looking at emotion processing, we're looking at perception of truth and susceptibility to misinformation across language. which is we have so many interesting projects and there is enough work for lifetime, many more lifetimes. I think it's a field that has been understudied up until relatively very recently in the history of science. Dr. Marion, I want to thank you for joining me today. This has been really fascinating. I appreciate your taking the time. Thank you for having me.
我们正在研究情感处理，我们正在研究不同语言中对真相的感知以及对虚假信息的易感性。我们有这么多有趣的项目，有一辈子的工作，甚至更多的生命。我认为这是一个在科学史上直到相对非常晚近之前一直被研究不足的领域。玛丽安博士，我要感谢你今天加入我。这真的很迷人。我很感谢你抽出时间。谢谢你邀请我。
I really enjoy talking to you and I enjoy talking about these issues. And I hope that people who speak two or more languages and even those who don't enjoy the conversation we have and want to dig in deeper and look at some of the studies, read the book and find out more about the relationship between language and thought. And let's all go out there and learn a new language. Absolutely. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www.combeckycichogicology.org or on Apple, spot, YouTube or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, please leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Wynerman. Our sound editor is Chris Kondyne.
我真的很喜欢和你交谈，我也喜欢谈论这些问题。我希望说两种或多种语言的人，甚至那些不会说这些语言的人，都能喜欢我们进行的对话，并希望深入挖掘，看一些研究，读这本书，并更多地了解语言和思想之间的关系。让我们所有人都去学习一门新语言吧。绝对的。你可以在我们的www.combeckycichogicology.org网站上找到《心理学谈话》以前的节目，也可以在Apple、Spotify、YouTube或你获取播客的任何地方找到。如果你喜欢你所听到的，请给我们留下评论。如果你对未来的播客有评论或想法，你可以发送电子邮件至speaking of psychology at APA.org。播客《心理学谈话》由李·温纳曼制作。我们的声音编辑是克里斯·孔丁。
Thank you for listening for the American Psychological Association. I'm Kim Mills. Enjoy more ways to save at Ralph's, like low prices in every aisle. And when you download the Ralph's app, you can clip and save more with digital coupons every week. Plus, you can earn fuel points to save up to $1 per gallon at the pump. At Ralph's, you can enjoy more ways to save and more rewards every time you shop. So it's always easy to save big every day with savings and rewards. Ralph's SoCal for over 150 years. Savings may vary by state. Fuel restrictions apply. C-Sight for details. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
感谢收听美国心理学会的节目。我是金·米尔斯。在拉尔夫斯超市享受更多省钱方式，例如每个过道都有低价。当您下载拉尔夫斯应用程序时，每周都可以通过数字优惠券剪辑并节省更多。此外，您还可以赚取加油积分，在加油站每加仑节省高达1美元。在拉尔夫斯超市，每次购物都可以享受更多省钱方式和更多奖励。因此，通过节省和奖励，每天都可以轻松省大钱。拉尔夫斯南加州150多年。各州节省额可能有所不同。燃料限制适用。详情请见网站。本集尚无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。